okay from university of washington
telling us about graphs and
arithmetic geometry the talk will be
from 11 to 11
50 and we'll have 10 minutes for
questions afterwards
thank you thanks for the invitation to
speak here and
thanks everyone for um joining the
zoom session it's nice to see so many
familiar faces and
many places that i would have liked to
meet in person hopefully
at some point everything that i talk
about
um which is my work is going to be
joined with robin the young
um at leiden university um
feel free to raise hand or just unmute
yourself if um
you have questions i do not check the
chat but if there are questions in the
chat
that need my attention um i guess
someone maybe chris can
bring it to my attention
thank you and um one other thing is i
miss the body language and uh human
interaction
so i i do maybe explain some things with
my hand if your
technology allows please keep my picture
also on your screen
um okay
maybe another warning is uh the work i'm
going to talk about is at the
intersection of many different fields
and i've done
try to make it accessible to everyone so
if i'm failing at that
you're welcome to stop me and make me
explain a little bit more
okay let me start by one claim
which says graphs are analogs of riemann
surfaces
so by a graph i will be a little bit
more clear what i mean but think of
an object which is graph-like and
riemann surface
i don't really need the definition but
it's some kind of a doughnut maybe
it has many holes and it has some extra
structure
first of all um this is not a
controversial claim
people in many different fields have
already exploited this analogy
saying geometric group theory there is
uh this notion of outer space
which is um a funny name for the space
of all graphs
um the reason um it's called outer space
people study other demorphisms of the
free group
by studying its action on this space
the same way that people study mapping
class group by studying
um the action on the titular space space
of riemann surfaces marketing raymond
surfaces
and there are other buzzwords in in
these fields that
relate riemann riemann surface situation
uh to its analog for graphs in
probability theory
people have been thinking of graphs as
riemann surface-like objects especially
in the theory of random blocks
you study green's functions um
especially in the case of
infinite graphs it gets you far in fact
one
very nice way of thinking of the object
do you see my cursor
the object on the left which is a graph
is an analog of this you can just think
of these lines
as being built from a very thin tubes
instead of just line so they have some
thickness and then if you think about it
these two pixels are essentially the
same this is just a thin version of this
and what probably sometimes do is to
sort of
guess certain properties of this by this
sort of
one would say um simple analogy of
thinking of lines as being tubes and
maybe guess what green's function should
look like and then prove it concretely
and then maybe closer to my field of
study and
to this audience is the notion of
tropical geometry um
there is this notion of divisor theory
riemann rock theory on graphs
um clear of jacobians which i will talk
about a little bit of
jacobi theory which sort of formally are
analogs of what people have studied
saying stream on
um on riemann surfaces and often the
proofs are still different they're not
um
sort of the same proof doesn't apply to
both situations
anyway so i will get back to this claim
of graphs being
analogs of riemann surfaces soon but let
me
say what i mean by graph
for me a graph is a first of all metric
graph most of the time
and metric graph is an object that
looks like this maybe a very quick way
of defining it
is a compact connected topological graph
by topological graph i mean you start
with a
sort of one-dimensional simplicial
complex and look at this geometric
realization but it also has a metric
and the metric is inner what does that
mean so metric
i suspect everyone knows what what that
means inner metric is a metric that the
distance between two points is the
shortest the length of the shortest path
between those two points so you can
define a path between
those points and then you can compute
the length and in general that length
doesn't have to be equal to the metric
of the metric space and inner metric or
length space is
inner metric space or length space is a
space that satisfies this equality
okay but in short i mean it's you start
with a graph like object and then you
have some numbers
which signifies if you go from here to
here maybe you don't want to take the
long path we just want to take the
shortest path
and it will be of length one
one crucial differences from the usual
notion of graph theory
graphs like combinatorial graphs is
the fact that all points are created
equal
so i allow myself to use points in
between edges
maybe
you can model if you want to tell a
computer you have this graph
you can actually pick a few points you
can maybe have
you have to put these branch points so
this lower point and the top point
but maybe you can also pick middle of
this left edge middle of the right
edge and then tell your computer my data
of metric graph
is this there are some arrows on these
edges which i don't
need for now but you can ignore that
i hope everyone agrees this data would
completely model this data
is that okay we call such a metric such
a
weighted graph and model for the metric
graph
but much more classically even before
graph theory people were thinking of
graphs modeling networks electrical
networks
the way that you should think of it is
these lines now are made out of
some copper wire
and the longer the copper the wire is
the more resistance you have
so you can think of this graph this
weighted graph or
this metric graph as being modeled by
some resistors
when you fix this model you're sort of
fixing the access points for this
electrical network
you you the places that you can plug in
a battery or
measure the voltage or things like that
sorry could you explain again why the
weighted graph models the measure graph
uh so i'm telling my computer that i
have
a line of length 4 by saying that it's
length 2 plus 2
and i have these branch points so
unfortunately i should have flipped this
90 degrees for the slide but
okay yeah that's what was confusing me
okay sounds good yeah
sorry any other questions
how does correctedness factor into the
the how the weighted graph models the
metrograph
sorry i didn't catch the first workbook
um so how does so in the second
picture there's i notice there's uh the
the edges are directed
um yes i i said ignore them i mean okay
it's useful
in some of the you can pick arbitrary
arrows if you want when you want to
write
concrete you'll see sometimes it's good
to put
arrows but the theory is independent of
the arrows i
i don't need i didn't need the arrows on
these slides
okay thanks
other questions
okay so let me start with this last
point of view the electrical network
theory and i will spend a few
slides on this and i will say things
that are mostly standard but
at least one or two things that is not
super standard um
even if you have seen electrical network
theory so i start with a function with
three variables
so i pick three points in my graph x y
and z and i will do the following i'm
going to put a battery between
y and z this is not the usual battery
you buy in a grocery store it's a
battery that fixes current
not voltage so when you buy a battery it
says like 1.5 volts
but you can actually spend a few hundred
dollars and buy something that fixes the
current
going to the network so you i send one
amps
to points y i remove
one amp to point from point z and i
fix my potential to be zero at z
and what i will do i will just go around
my metric graph and measure the voltage
between
x and z so in other words z zero so i
measure the voltage at x at all the
points in my graph
is that clear so again i have a battery
between y and z
which fixes currents and i'm measuring
voltage at various points x
and as i change x y and z i have three
choices and i get different numbers
okay i call this conveniently the j
function
um it's kind of a sort of potential
kernel to inverse laplacian but anyway
it doesn't matter too much
and i will define effective resistance
between two points as being sort of the
diagonal of this
i put x and x so if you think about it
in this graph
if i measure the voltage here x is equal
to y
then what's going to happen i have
current 1
going into y and exiting z and i'm
measuring the voltage
at y if you remember
v is equal to ri voltage is equal to
resistance times current current is one
so voltage should be equal to resistance
that's what i'm so it makes sense from
if you know any
sort of kirchhoff laws stuff it makes
sense to call such a thing
effective resistance between the two
points
okay maybe it's a good time to just
remind people
let me switch to my
camera what i mean is really
what you probably know
in my first example at
4 1 1 if i if this is my
x and this is my y if i ask what is
effective resistance between x
and y x and y well
you can use parallel one divided by four
plus one divided by one plus one divided
by 4 and you compute
r whatever that will give you r is equal
to r
okay this is 4 sir
i'm not saying anything
well what i am doing is i'm taking
this definition for the entire metric
graph that's probably not something that
in a basic electrical network setup you
usually fix a model first and then do
these things this quickly
but now i have a continuous function
essentially
all right up to here everything is sort
of known
um maybe something that's new
for most of the audience is this result
of uh chinberg and rumbly
and some very related result due to
shobu jiang these are all
arithmetic geometers so you should start
wondering why would they study
what i'm talking about here's the result
there is a unique measure
of total mass one i i didn't say
probability measure because this measure
can be negative
such that this double integral
will be maximized
okay i'll say more about this but let me
just say
why would anyone look at these kind of
measures by reminding you something
again from physics
or some intuitive statement from physics
which
is the following if you have just a
piece of metal let's say in r2
it's a flat piece of metal and you start
putting electric charge
of the same sign on this metal that's a
positive electric charge what will
happen is
these electric charges don't like each
other they repel
right and they would like to go to the
boundary
probably intuitively you agree they
would like to go to the boundary
to maximize their mutual distances from
each other
right
such a measure so it's such a eventual
configuration of uh
electric charge is sort of there is some
distribution you call it equilibrium
measure when things settle
this these things go away and go to the
corner maybe you even
believe that sharper corners should have
more charges if you think about it
sharper corners and mutual distances
have a smaller contribution to the
entire
mutual distance the way that electric
charges would behave probably they would
like to make the total
mutual distances maximum they want to be
as far away from each other as possible
in total as a system
right and then you can define a notion
of capacity based on what is
the total mutual distances when
everything settles that's a
kind of measure of how much electric
charge a
piece of metal can hold depending on its
shape
and the notion of capacitor is very much
related to that
so i was in a way i'm going back to my
slides now i'm going
the total mutual distances is this
double integral that i had
effective resistance gives you a notion
of distance on the graph
i'm looking at total mutual distances
and i'm looking for a configuration
equilibrium
configuration nu which is my a unique
measure of total mass 1
that makes total mutual distances
maximum
okay i'm looking at capacity of the
graph in some sense
where the distance
the distance is measured by effective
resistance it's a very natural thing to
do
okay not only this uh schinberg and
romney actually do a nice computation
and say what this equilibrium measure is
the equilibrium measure i don't really
need
all the details of this but i will need
essentially this
definition of fe
the measure that maximizes this func
this energy
is it has a discrete part in red which i
don't want to dwell on too much it's
number of directions at any point that
at that point minus two so it's this
this discrete part is
zero most of the time because most
points on graph have only two directions
you will pick up a delta measure
whenever your degree is not two
but then there is a continuous part
which is more interesting
you start with the label measure on so
any line
in the graph is just like an interval so
you have a lebec measure for that where
the total the back measure is the length
of that interval
what i will do i will just rescale that
length by something which is f of e it's
called foster's coefficient and it has a
very
interesting interpretation so one
interpretation which is easy for me to
state is one minus effective resistance
across the
endpoints divided by the length of that
edge
that's a self-contained description
maybe another one which is more
interesting
and brings in probability is that it's
probably of a random edge
sorry a probability of a given edge the
edge e
not being in a uniform random spanning
tree
okay so there's a interesting theory of
random spanning trees you can
learn in any interesting literature
maybe lions and um
[Music]
perez's book is a very nice place to
start
and these numbers have been studied so
the equilibrium measure for
maximizing this energy somehow
realizing that capacity is up to some
discrete part
is very much related to random spanning
trees
so here the r uh r of e minus and e plus
is just like the
and using the kirchhoff rule
the effective resistance across the
endpoints yeah like so you
account for all the other paths going
from e minus and plus which depend on
the lengths of the paths
is that correct yes so it's the
kirchhoff rule um
like in the example i had in my uh yeah
right up the top and bottom of the thing
that's r
of all these edges um across all these
edges
but each edge will be divided by the
length
so i see yeah
yeah sounds good
other questions i see some things are
happening on the chat but i'm not
checking it so i i'm relying on quiz to
tell me if i have to
answer anything i have a question about
the function
r so are we only talking about the
effective resistance function for
circuits or um are there like other
general properties
are we talking about general metrics for
r or r
is um just the effective resistance it
does give a metric
okay it is true that if you fix any
other metric you can ask
the same question but the two natural
metrics that you should
you can consider one of them is just the
original metric it was a metric space
you could use the original metric and
ask the same question
it turns out this metric is more
interesting because it relates to
harmonic analysis
um laplacians and
yeah it's a more natural thing for at
least from the perspective of number
theory
okay that's cool
other questions
okay so in fact i don't really care
about this um
equilibrium measure in this stock but i
do care a lot about the
value of the maximum the capacity of the
graph
so this measure will give you some
maximum and i will call that
tile capacity it's a it's the maximum of
the energy functional
and okay so i've given you a definition
um it's not very computational here is
another definition
it's a lemma that you can show this
value of the capacity
you can compute it by the following
method you look at the function
f fix a point q it turns out your final
answer will be independent of the q
and then for any other point in the
graph compute the effective resistance
between
the given point x to that q
that gives you a function on the graph
and by treating all these
lines in the graph as being intervals
you can
either take a derivative look at the
derivative of that
square that and integrate over the
entire graph and you get
this tau this capacity it's a lemma not
so difficult
this is i mean i've written it in an
easy way but you could
say it more fancily this is sort of
dirichlet product of f with itself
but don't worry about it okay this is a
satisfactory thing if i give you a
metric graph you can compute this style
using this formula
but in fact it would be nice to have
something that computer can compute so
let's get rid of this
integral and there is a proposition or
lemma that
um sort of at least implicitly has
already appeared in
a work of yet another arithmetic
geometer the
shinker zubair was zubair schinker was a
student of bromley another number
uh again arithmetic geometer and
for some reason he studied this quantity
as well
in fact his phd thesis was about tau
it's 250 pages
um studying properties of time
and in the particular format i'm writing
here it's it's a result of ours and the
proof is slightly different but anyway
you can compute this tau
very concretely so again i don't care
about exactly what
um i mean this is effective resistance
function
for you fix a model for any edge you
compute a bunch of effective resistances
this f of e was this foster's
coefficient which was
related to probability or effective
resistance
all i want you to notice is that this is
very easy to compute
using linear algebra so
all these quantities effective
resistances are linear algebraic
quantities you can compute if you know
the laplacian of the graph
the combinatorial laplacian of the graph
okay so the take-home message from this
slide is there is this notion of
capacity it can be computed and in fact
it can be computed really fast and um
maybe i will end this discussion by
saying that
um romney also had this inequality
that tau is at most one-fourth total
length of the
graph so just add all the edge lengths
of all pieces
all the edges that you see divided by
four
and it already holds if and only if the
graph is a tree
it's contractible i'll get back to all
these points
soon any questions about this i'm going
to move to
something seemingly different about
graphs i'm done with electrical networks
no questions okay let me
switch gears and talk about geometry of
graphs this is more
related to tropical geometry or
non-archimedean geometry but
the definition is very basic for any
metric graph you can define something
called it's jacobian
and this is again by analogy you might
have heard
curves or riemann surfaces also have
something some
object called jacobians attached to them
in this case if you have a
metric graph of
genus g by genus i mean
rank of the fundamental group or very
concretely if you fix a model for your
graph just count the number of edges
minus number of vertices plus one
so any graph there is this integer that
you can attach
to and i'm saying any metric graph has a
g-dimensional real torus attached to it
and it's more than that it has a
polarization
okay so let me say what this object is
in very concrete terms
um you look at integer values flows and
you can you look at real values flows on
your graph
for this let me actually change again to
my
camera
now i put arrows because i want to put
some numbers which are
directional um forget about the lengths
in fact for now i am integer valued and
real value source has nothing to do with
lengths
i'm going to put maybe a number 2 here
minus 1 here and minus 1 here
i claim this assignment of numbers is
kind of
um it gives you a flow because at any
point the incoming flow and
outgoing flow is going to be equal
it's pretty clear at any point along the
way
two is coming in two is going out there
is no problem on the left
at here two is coming in but then there
is a minus one coming in in other words
one is going out one is going out
so there is some sort of conservation at
every point you call such a thing a flow
okay and then you have integer value
flows meaning that the numbers that i
wrote down
are integers and you can have real value
flows
maybe pi plus e comes down
e goes up pi goes up
that's a real value so right
let me um remind you that first of all
the space of all real value flows it's
going to be a vector space
because you can add to add or subtract
flows you get flows
and you can scale them you can multiply
any all these numbers by
square root of two and you still have a
flow it's a vector space
and space of all integer value flows is
not a vector space
but it's a sort of z module inside the
vector space it's a lattice inside the
vector space
okay but let me also emphasize that in
everything i'm saying here i forgot the
length information i'm not really
remembering that the length of the left
one was 4
1 4 or anything like that
these spaces are not taking into account
the lengths but that's where the
polarization comes in polarization will
remember those extra data
let me go back to my slides
so this jacobian that i want to be a
real
taurus i think you already can guess
what i'm going to do i have a vector
space of real valued flows i have a
lattice inside it
that sounds a lot like a taurus i'm
going to look at the quotient of
the vector space by this lattice and i'm
going to do an example in a moment
again i remind you that i was forgetting
the
length the data and i want to somewhat
encode that
what i'm going to do i take this
polarization to be the cycle
intersection pairing so what do i mean
by that
the space of flows can be generated by
cycles
if you just pick a cycle in your graph a
simple closed path
you can put a flow which is just
circulating on that cycle
right is that clear
and it's a basic fact that all flows are
combinations of these basic flows
you can make any flow on the graph if
you just know the cycle
flows on the graph and this is true both
in the
real valued space and integer valued
space so
they give a generating set for the
lattice which at the same time
almost trivially will give you the
vector space
basis so what is in cycle intersection
pairing now
now i want you to see my picture if you
are just looking at the slides
if you have two cycles you can define a
pairing between them
the product between them where remembers
the length of the intersection
that's cycle intersection so if the two
cycles are
disjoint cycle one time cycle two is
going to be zero
if the two cycles have some intersection
you remember the length of the
intersection
okay this is cycle intersection pairing
on
in some way it's not clear but it's some
mysterious way i'm remembering some
length data anyway right
it's it's not super clear whether i'm
remembering every length data but that's
that's a whole different interesting
question that
relates to something else that i don't
want to talk about
any question about jacobians
is this pairing degenerate
non-degenerate
it's perfect pairing so it's positive
definite
symmetric
yeah quite bilinear form positive
definite
there's a question from the audience if
the cycles are oppositely oriented
on their intersection is there
cancellation
uh yes so it's um
i mean i have done all these things in
terms of the homology first
which i didn't want to talk about and
these things are all
if you want to write them well let me
let me do the next slide with the
example yes if if you if in your
orientation that you have fixed
you don't need an orientation to define
everything i define
but if you are thinking as i will in the
next slide as
cycles being oriented then yes you have
cancellations too
so you have e times e is one e times
minus is minus one so you have
uh signed computations
let me do maybe the next example and
then i will come back
so let's look at the same example we
have been looking at i'm forgetting the
length theta for now
um the cycles in this graph are e1 minus
e3
or some basic cycles in this graph are
e1 minus e3 so it's the outer cycle i'm
coming down on the left
going up on the right that's this point
i have the zero flow put zero everywhere
if i put one and minus one i have this
flow this simple cycle
i have e1 minus e2 come down here go up
there
and i have e2 minus e3 that's kind of
redundant but let me say it
i have these basic vectors inside
the space of flows
the way that i've drawn this is actually
remembering some
um angles and angles are related to dot
products
and like e1 minus e2 dots e1 minus e3 so
the circ the e1 minus e2 cycle and e1
minus e3 cycle
have this e1 in common and what i will
do i will remember the length of e1
squared sorry length of v1 not squared
length of v1 will will be
will be the dot product between this
vector and this vector
okay and then use the cosine formula to
compute the angle between the two if you
have the dot product and you have the
lengths
i guess the way that i've drawn this
picture i'm assuming all the edge
lengths are now one one one one then i
get 60 degree angles here
is that clear and i think it's now also
clear that you can have
minus e1 minus this element e1 minus e2
so e2
minus e3 is where my cursor is now and
then yes you have
angles more than 90 degrees so this
product can have negative values too
is that okay did i answer the question
in the chat
okay so the tours that i'm going to
think about is this
this is the fundamental domain for the
taurus of course you can
make identification of opposite edges
and you can draw it as the force if you
like
but this is just remember this is not
kind of a
only a taurus there is also a bilinear
form maybe
you can think of the tangent at the
origin and you're fixing it by linear
form on the tangent space or
universal cover or whatever i mean you
can
describe this product as some extra
information in various ways
i called it polarization and i i must
say i noticed in the next talk
uh this notion of sort of maybe not
jacobians but tropical obedient
varieties
comes into the um talk and i
suspect this should be relevant um
explanation for what is a polarized
tropical obedient variety
okay do you mind explaining
um one more minute like what the uh
where you got those angles from again
because i understood that
it seems like so you said you got like
e1 was the product but then how did that
e1 turn into a 60 degree angle
yeah let me do that with a piece of
paper
so you have e1 minus e2 this is 1 e1
e2 e3 and you have
e1 minus e3 for example their product
will remember the length of e1
because the intersection of these two
cycles is just e one
and let's assume that length is one then
you have the cosine of theta
is the product of um let's call this c
one let's call this c two is product of
c1 and c2
divided by length of c1
length of c2 and if i'm assuming all the
edge lengths are equal to
1 then i'm looking at 1 divided by two
and that will be
cosine of 60 degrees right
okay cool interesting
if you change edge length this
computation is gonna sort of your taurus
is going to be
um tilted the the lattice is going to be
the angles are going to change
so somehow the angles will will remember
the edges
and in fact i mean there is something
called tropical thoralic theorem that it
says
you can essentially reconstruct the
graph from this data but that's the
thing i said i don't want to talk about
i'll be happy to chat later
other questions
okay now i'm going to define a function
on this space of flows
which does the following rather
useful thing if you give me a flow i'm
going to find the closest
integer flow and i will remember the
distance
squared from that integer flow
okay it's the so i'm looking at the
product
of the x minus lambda x minus lambda
where lambda is the
is an integer flow and i'm looking at
finding the closest
integer flow it's the closest vector
problem
in that is theory so you have an element
of the vector space
you're finding the closest points in the
lattice
to that space to that point and you're
remembering how far you are
you can think of this as like a
quantization problem uh
your data is in a vector space and your
digital data the thing that you want to
give feed to your computer is this
discrete data of
the lattice and this is like the error
for your
quantization is that clear
for some reason i call it absolute value
of theta but that comes because of the
arithmetic geometry
context one
observation is that this function is
periodic with respect to the lattice
is that clear
let me once again switch i didn't intend
to switch
so many times but now that i'm used to
it i'll do it
so if you have in this previous picture
you have this lattice
like given an element of the vector
space here this
is the origin this function theta will
remember the closest lattice
point which is maybe this and remember
this this distance squared
and the periodicity is that if you give
me a point which is a shift of this with
respect
with with the with the lattice element
then the output will be again the same
that's the periodicity statement that i
was saying
right
any question about this
all right so it's a periodic function it
descends to the jacobi and remember
my jacobian was just the space of la
this is modulo the
space of uh flows modulo the integer
flows
if it's a periodic function in fact i
have a function on the jacobian now
it's a real valued function and what i
can do is i can just integrate this
function on the jacobian with respect to
probability har measure so there is a
natural measure on
on any compact house or compact group
called
har measure i will normalize it by
saying that
the total measure is one and i'm
computing this number
if you know voronoi decompositions for
lattices so a voronoi cell
is the space of the the set of all
points that are closest
let's say to the origin what i'm really
doing i'm just computing the
second moment of that polytope i'm
looking at z dot z
and i'm integrating over that polytope
this is mostly for people that know
variability compositions but i've
technically given you the definition
and in that sense it's really a quantity
that's been studied uh before
um it's a quantity that in the quantizer
interpretation it's computing the mean
squared error for the quantization
so it's saying on average what's the
error for for the quantizer
okay so
now i have yet another quantity you give
me a metric graph i go through all the
machinery i
introduced in the past few slides and i
compute another number and remember in
the previous
discussion i had yet another number
called capacity of the
of the metric graph and i can now
present the first
result
these two numbers are related in they're
very different animals i mean this comes
from the geometry this comes from
potential theory or
electrical networks and surprisingly
they have a very
simple relationship between them so this
capacity up to some constants the
capacity plus
this moment of the voronoi
is just a total length it's a linear
relation between them
okay so a few remarks first of all the
proof of this um
well maybe the first question is how
would you even guess such a thing is
true i'll
address it at the end of this slide but
the proof of this actually goes through
a
range of different topics which there
are many experts in the audience
um we do need probability theory i
already mentioned some connections with
random spanning trees we do need of
course combinatorics we're
doing graph theory convex geometry we're
studying voronoi polytopes for example
an electron networks definition
and it's kind of uh elementary proof but
rather surprising that it works
let me just as a consequence let me tell
you
tau was computable remember there was
this formula that i said you don't have
to memorize it just remember
you can compute this fast now you can
compute
i because the total length is easy you
can compute tau
so you can compute i from this formula
and that's already somewhat surprising
i for a general lattice is expected to
be very hard to compute
and it should be worse than sharpie
heart
and in fact some um even for the
lattices we consider
a lot of computational questions are
difficult
for example the number of vertices of
the voronoi cell
of our lattice is sharply hard to
compute
and there were good reasons that people
would
i think it's still open the sharp or
difficulty of computation of moment of a
general lattice is still open
and there was some attempt to try to
prove it using
our lattices somehow they bring in
combinatories and allow you to use
usual reductions in computer science and
so i mean from computational complexity
perspective was also surprising
let me make another point in a way this
is making romney's inequality into
equality we are giving the error term
romney was saying tau
is less than or equal to one-fourth l
and we are saying the difference between
the two is actually this i
we are we are computing the error term
in terms of the moment of the boron
associated volume of the flow space
and this number is bigger than or equal
to zero by construction its moment
second moment and it's zero precisely
where when jacobian the lattice is just
a point
and if you think about it that means you
don't have a flow in your graph which
means your graph doesn't have a cycle
which means it's a
so this is not the easiest proof of
romney's inequality but
it gives that as a consequence and it
it gives the error term
and um the way that we came up with this
conjecture before we have the proof is
actually by analogy with
riemann surfaces so there's a remarkable
result due to
robert wilms on faulting's delta
invariant and somehow
with degeneration we expect that such a
thing should be true
and then the proof of it the proof of
robert is very analytic and it wouldn't
carry on to our situation we had to do
things by hand
okay
and and then remaining a few minutes i
want to say a few things but how
is this what the second part of my title
was arithmetic geometry how is this
related to any
any number theory or arithmetic geometry
okay
and it will be for some time
philosophical in my last slide i'll say
a result which puts this into a context
any question before i move on to
arithmetic geometry well
um it's not going to be serious
arithmetic geometry but
let me let me go back to the question of
graphs versus remote surfaces
uh in the first slide i said they are
sort of morally
analogs i want to be more precise how is
it that graphs actually
the sort of qualitative analogy is not
good enough for our
application i want a more robust
connection
and for that let's go back to uh the
context of
sort of very classical geometry uh if
you have a variety over c
think of it as a collection of zero sets
of polynomial
zero set of a collection of polynomials
and in fact for this slide and for for
some time it's
good enough to think about polynomial
zero in one variable so you have
the zero polynomial in c
square bracket z and you look at the
zero set of that zero equal to zero
well zero equal to zero is always true
so
the zero set will be the complex numbers
but algebraic geometry tells you that
you should the topology that you should
put on that set
is the risky topology meaning that you
should consider the zero sets of more
polynomials
so close sets in the risky topology in
the
running example we have the complex
plane these close sets are going to be
finite points
finite set of points or the entire thing
or empty set
open sets will be co-finite sets and of
course that's ridiculous you don't want
to study that
space you don't want to study the
complex analysis course using this
silly topology you don't want to use the
risky topology to do analysis
so what you do in a complex analysis
course you switch
to you remember c has absolute value
and use that absolute value to
give analytic constructions
if you do it with a1 which is the zero
polynomial situation you actually
if you run this program you get the
complex plane
with the usual topology analytic
topology if you do it with curves you
get what is called riemann surfaces
and if you do it with a billion
varieties you get complex torii
um there are fields out there that are
not like complex numbers there are
so called non-archimedean fields they
have absolute values but the absolute
value is actually
the usual triangular code is stronger
it's not
absolute value of x plus y is sum of
absolute value of x sum of absolute
and absolute value of y but rather just
a maximum
and these are very common fields out
there so number theorists would
probably think of periodic numbers and
its extensions geometers might
think of formal neuron series if you are
neither
you can just know the fact that almost
all fields are non-archimedean
so somehow there's a theorem due to
ostrovsky and then later on
follows from the work of gelfand and
mazer that says
any complete archimedean field is
essentially just r or c
but there are many many many fields out
there that are so
somehow the common random field in the
street is going to be non-archimedean
and it's it's
reasonable to ask how would you do the
program
up there if you start with a variety you
can look at the zero sets with the
zersky topology
you might not like that for obvious
reasons you might want to use the
absolute value
and come up with a new topology that you
can do analysis
and the sad thing is that you will
always get a totally disconnected
space a type of space that's not good
for analysis
when you do exactly what you did for for
c
and then i'm going to show you some
pictures berkovic
realized there is a way to canonically
add points to the story disconnected
space and make it a
very nice space topologically which is
ready to do analysis
okay so i'm not going to tell you how he
does it but i'll show you some pictures
berkovic a1 so you have this totally
disconnected
space think of it as these uh dots at
the bottom of this tree and then
berkovic
creates all these extra points
and somehow makes a tree out of them
this is a schematic picture
which i stole from matthias johnson's
paper but
so you get a tree all i want to say is
that when you run the machinery of
berkovic you get a tree
okay and similarly
riemann surfaces locally look like a
piece of complex plane
if you think about curves now over in
our comedian fields they locally look
like a tree
because complex plane has turned into a
tree
things that are locally like a tree
globally are going to be graphs
so somehow graphs are riemann surfaces
in some sense
except that there are not remount
surfaces over c there are riemann
surfaces over
non-archimedean fields okay
and that gives you a technology to take
a
question over another comedian fields to
graph theory
which is a sort of source of a lot of
interesting combinatorics
if you run this program for curves as i
said you get graphs and it turns out any
graph actually appears as a
fundamental sort of part of
this skeleton this dumbbell graph any
graph appears
inside the curve in this setup in this
situation
and similarly for a billion varieties um
you get real torii
so let me go back and say what i was
really doing in the first part of my
talk
when i was doing electrical network
theory i was actually doing something
potential theory over analytic curves
over non-archimedean riemann surfaces
it's sort of a fancy way of putting
putting the
initial computation and any curve has a
jacobian you can look at this their
analytic berkovici stuff and
as i said curves give you graphs
obedient varieties give you
real torai and i was really studying
the moment of of the met
of the jacobian of the metric graph is a
quantity attached to the jacobian of the
curve
okay all right so
let me end by saying that um just
summarizing how the result fits into
what um a number of theories might care
about
if you start with a obedient variety
i don't want to do all too much on these
terms it's a discrete math um
conference i'll be happy to chat later
but let's say elliptic curve you
probably have heard about elliptic curve
or at this wire stress equation y
squared is equal to x3 plus x plus one
just take a very concrete thing these
are called the billion varieties
there are two numbers that you can
attach to this data
principally polarizability variety and
they capture the complexity how complex
these things are
one of them is due to faultings the
other one is
extension of the work of neron and tate
and with robindeon we have this
other paper that proves that these two
quantities are related in this way
so the faulting sides the complexity
number one is equal to
complexity number two plus some local
data
and the local data is i invariant of all
these analytics picture so for any
at place at infinity for the archimedean
place you get a complex force you can
compute a number from that
for any prime number
you get a real torus and you can compute
this
moment for it and i was essentially
telling you how to compute
these moments in terms of capacity
theory
okay so the last slide is first of all
the proof of this theorem is actually
which it's not combinatorics but what i
want to emphasize is that for jacobians
i was telling you how to compute these
numbers
in terms of capacities
and probably you don't care much about
these things the the result
extends something that people knew for
elliptic curves and
partial results in this direction were
due to boston hendry and
artesia and wagner
and some other people and yeah it gives
some
concrete results in turn for faulting's
height
in terms of local decomposition which
i'll be happy to check later
anyway thanks for your attention
hey thanks for a great talk let's thank
our speaker
are there any